all right Aubry we are celebrating a
hundred episodes of marriage boot camp
God is this show over yet you were on it
you were on it a minute ago
twice is there something you learned
that you still apply in your everyday
life what you learned on this show yes
when you get in an argument with someone
you tell them what you feel and then
when they tell you what youth what they
feel you have to say I totally hear what
you're saying when you want me to be
calmer when we get in discussions and
not get too crazy you have to like
acknowledge their feelings and then say
the next time it works like a charm
people up because they aren't expecting
you to acknowledge their feelings
everybody's like waiting to talk over
each other but yeah that's men like
helps me in business like when I tell
MTV that they need to put making the
band back on with the original cast
members instead of some new young kids
that no one will care about I have to
tell all the heads at MTV I totally
understand your concern and TV but I
think that my idea might be even better
I think there's definitely an audience
for that one like 10 plus years since
making the band what would you tell
Aubree on that first audition day
knowing what you know now child I would
say don't be so offended by Diddy and
listen to him more because there were
keys of success that he taught me that I
fought for a little too long enjoy life
it's really not that serious
everybody's gonna post your stretch
marks and you're coming out if you get a
few undie shots on the internet calm
down even Julia Roberts probably has
them and
[Music]
be careful about dating men with the
last name Trump okay that's a pretty
good life lesson you made some headlines
this summer because you would refer to
him as a soul mate yeah do you still
feel that way always why is that why do
you feel like Donald Trump jr. is your
soul mate because well have you ever had
a soul mate okay so I believe that you
can have many soul mates in life they're
not just people that you're physically
intimate with they're people that you
can be family with or best friends with
and it's people that share and connect
with your soul at a certain time in a
certain place in life I used to think
that it was just like a Q word that I
threw around but now as I've gotten
older I find very few people that I
actually want to connect Souls with and
they're not on hinge are you at all
still in contact with him or is it just
a soul connection you know I'm not gonna
answer that question would you still be
in contact with me the trumps confuse me
so I don't know abre yeah I know you
have changed up your looked a lot since
the making the ban base and people love
to come for you or doing God
I'm just getting eaten alive right now
why every scene I'm a plastic surgery
nightmare and they call you
unrecognizable I'm looking at you right
now you got the same face whatever it is
I use like I'll put all those like
snapchat filters and wigs and like
everybody loses their mind like let's
join the New Age now and understand what
is filter is and does to a face take a
deep breath what is your message to
those haters who love to get in those
Instagram comments I noticed you went
private on Instagram I'm just it's a
little thing called honey trapping
whenever you're on a scandal you put
your Instagram on private and you can
trap like 20,000 followers a day thank
you for making my Instagram numbers go
up I love you hatin ass
I love that message all right Danity
Kane I know we're out there on the road
doing shows are we getting new music a
new album anytime soon yes we actually
probably dropping a single new Kings
coming up Don and I always like we wake
up and were like should we do it today
and then I'm like no let's make him wait
we're gonna do it soon and this it's an
incredible track it's beautiful oh
every Danity Kane track is incredible it
really is I mean I'm not I would I would
confront you if you were wrong but
you're not and this all this time out on
the road going to events like this have
you found time to date to find any new
guys what are you looking for if not
okay so no I've been on a couple dates
from hinge they were so scary I could be
here all night telling you about my
experiences I could write a book one day
and I probably will but um nowadays I
just literally watch 90-day fiance and
I'm really thinking about getting myself
a nice little Moroccan man you know what
I'm saying if all the men can go to
Colombia and get themself a little honey
why can't I would you then go on 90 day
fiancé would you put yourself out there
like but I'll see please do a celebrity
edition of 90 day fiancé I would do it
in a heartbeat I really believe you can
find sincere love in situations like
that I do I'm dying all right we will
leave it on that because I don't think
we can get any better than that all
right thank you so much my my Rebecca
bye Sahid if you watch the 90 day fiancé
you know what I'm talking about
[Music]
[Applause]